Rammstein am Freitag internationale
ukraine-konferenz der Mann der hier
telefonierend mitten in der Weltlage
steht weiß zu Beginn der Woche selbst
noch nicht dass er Deutschlands neuer
Verteidigungsminister sein wird Inhaber
der befehls- und Kommando Gewalt und
wohl noch nie war die Aufgabe gewaltiger
Boris Pistorius muss die Zeiten wenn der
retten das größte Versprechen des
Kanzlers der Oppositionsführer erhöht
den Druck
ich will es mal militärisch sagen das
ist die letzte Patrone wenn dieser
Verteidigungsminister keinen Erfolg hat
dann scheitert die ganze Bundesregierung
dafür dass er nun Scholz
schicksalsminister sein könnte steht
Pistorius am Tag seiner Ernennung
ziemlich alleine vor den Kameras wann
der Kanzlerin angerufen hat wird er
gefragt gestern
geregelt hat Olaf Scholz die wichtigste
personaldesigner Zeiten wenn der
Regierung erst am Tag von Christine
lambrechts Rücktritt seit 3 Januar weiß
er davon von ihren Plänen in der
SPD-Spitze Erleichterung über die Lösung
ein Interview geben will uns niemand
mehr
es ist auch die Woche an deren Ende die
Entscheidung über deutsche
leopardlieferungen steht auf die Grüne
und FDP drängen Mittwoch
Verteidigungsausschuss wird sich mit
Pistorius etwas ändern am deutschen nein
die grüne verteidigungspolitikerin Nanni
macht sich über seinen Spielraum keine
Illusion
ich sehe ihn weder auf der Seite
derjenigen die da stark bremsen könnten
noch auf der Seite derjenigen die da
stark pushen von daher bleibt das
sozusagen eine Entscheidung die vor
allem im Kanzleramt maßgeblich getroffen
wird
Sicherheitspolitik zeitenwände das ist
Chefsache gemanagt von Scholz engem
vertrauten Kanzleramtsminister Schmidt
das Verteidigungsministerium als
defensivposten dieses Bild hat die
unambitionierte Christine Lambrecht
geprägt
Boris Pistorius gilt als anderes Kaliber
als Offensivkraft sein neuer
Kabinettskollege der FDP Finanzminister
hofft dass sich mit Pistorius
Grundlegendes ändert in Lindners Worten
schwingt Enttäuschung mit wir haben
jetzt eine neue Besetzung im
Verteidigungsministerium und ich
verbinde damit auch die Erwartung dass
wir bei der tüchtigung der Bundeswehr
jetzt noch schnellere Fortschritte
erzielen wir werden seitens des
Finanzministeriums das auch aktiv
unterstützen das Angebot bestand und ich
glaube es wird jetzt auch anders
angenommen anders als bisher der
Oppositionsführer wird noch deutlicher
der Verteidigungsetat ist nicht
gestiegen wie der Bundeskanzlers
angekündigt hat sondern er ist um 300
Millionen Euro gesunken gegenüber dem
letzten Jahr der Bundeskanzler löst
seine eigenen Zusagen nicht ein ich habe
wirklich die Hoffnung dass der neue
Verteidigungsminister das jetzt anders
sieht anders durchsetzt auf Pistorius
warten die großen unerledigten Aufgaben
der Seitenwände von 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen ist bei der Truppe
bislang fast nichts angekommen die
Reform der Streitkräfte die
Neuorganisation des Beschaffungswesens
eine Strategie für die Rüstungsindustrie
alles liegengeblieben Militärexperten
sprechen von einem verlorenen Jahr
man kann die zeitenwände nicht aus dem
Kanzleramt führen ich glaube dass das im
letzten Jahr auch Wolfgang Schmidt und
Olaf Scholz ein bisschen so gedacht
haben und damit haben sie und jetzt
hängt es eben doch dann von einem
historius ab was er konkret in den
nächsten drei Jahren erreicht
in Ramstein lässt Scholz seinen
Verteidigungsminister wenig erreichen
Pistorius hatte Entscheidungen zu
leopardlieferungen angekündigt eine
Einigung gibt es nicht Irritation bei
Verbündeten Koalitionspartnern er
versucht Handlungsfähigkeit zu
demonstrieren deswegen habe ich heute
morgen meinem Haus den Auftrag erteilt
eine Prüfung vorzunehmen über die
Bestände von Leopard Panzern der
verschiedenen Typen das Christine
Lambrecht eine Bestandsaufnahme kurz vor
Rammstein verboten habe berichtet
Business Insider auch nach
zdf-information hat sie keine aktuellen
Zahlen abrufen lassen um den Kanzler
nicht unter Zugzwang zu setzen die Augen
sind nun auf Pistorius gerichtet wie
viel Spielraum in der Kanzler lässt und
wie viel er sich erkämpft
ein Verteidigungsminister mit
beschränkter Beinfreiheit und dazu
heftiges ampelge mit der Zeit also
nachzufragen und dazu begrüße ich live
im Studio den
FDP-Generalsekretär
schönen guten Abend guten Abend hat ihre
Parteikollegin Strack Zimmermann wie es
von dem
SPD-Fraktionschef gesagt wurde
Schnappatmung oder hat sie recht mit
ihrer Kritik
wir wollen alle dass dieser Krieg bald
zu Ende geht wir wollen dass dieser
Krieg mit einem Sieg der Ukraine zu Ende
geht und wir sind uns alle hoffentlich
einig in dieser Koalition dass der Sieg
der Ukraine nicht vom Himmel fallen wird
und auch kein Selbstläufer sein wird das
heißt wir müssen einiges dafür tun vor
allem müssen wir sehr genau zuhören was
die Ukraine in dieser konkreten
Situation braucht wir sollten übrigens
auch zuhören was unsere östlichen
Partner Verbündete innerhalb der NATO
als Organisation und zu sagen uns
empfehlen und dementsprechend sollten
wir dann international abgestimmt die
Ukraine unterstützt werden verlange ich
auch von ihnen dass sie meiner Frage
zuhören die haben sie jetzt nicht
beantwortet
Schnappatmung oder hat sie recht mit
ihrer Kritik nein es ist doch bekannt
seit vielen Wochen und Monaten das
innerhalb der Koalitionen zum Teil auch
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen existiert
wir sind aber der Meinung sie haben ja
mich als Generalsekretär der FDP
eingeladen und nicht als Sprecher der
Ampel Koalition und ich sage Ihnen wir
müssen mehr tun und vor allem wir müssen
die Ukraine jetzt konkret unterstützen
und die Zeit spielt in dieser Situation
eine besondere Rolle denn die Zeit haben
wir derzeit nicht wir vermuten ich
vermute dass demnächst eine mögliche
Offensive Russlands ansteht und ich
glaube dass die ukrainische Armee die
Soldaten und Soldaten die gerade dort
kämpfen derzeit massiv Unterstützung
brauchen noch mal teilen Sie die Kritik
von Frau strak Zimmermann am Kanzler ich
meine wir müssen ja über diese Dinge
reden ich kann die Bedenken und die
Sorgen des Bundeskanzlers aber auch die
Punkte die aus der SPD-Fraktion
vorgetragen werden die kann ich
nachvollziehen ich kann das verstehen
und ich habe auch großen Respekt vor
diese Position aber wir sind der Meinung
dass wir jetzt hier einen anderen Weg
geben müssen wie geht's jetzt weiter ich
gehe fest ich gehe fest davon aus dass
in den nächsten Tagen möglicherweise
vielleicht auch in den nächsten Wochen
die Prüfung abgeschlossen ist dann
wissen wir mehr aus meiner Sicht müssten
wir in der Zwischenzeit ernsthaft
darüber nachdenken welche
Rahmenbedingungen oder Genehmigung wir
freigeben könnten damit andere bestimmte
Maßnahmen umsetzen könnten dass dafür
wir machen das könnten wir sehr konkret
aus meiner Sicht machen allerdings das
werden wir gemeinsam in der Koalition
entscheiden das heißt sie erwarten wenn
ich das nochmal zusammenfassen darf in
den nächsten Tagen oder möglicherweise
auch Wochen eine klare Entscheidung zum
weiteren Vorgehen mit dem Leopard Panzer
wir brauchen in den nächsten Tagen in
den nächsten Wochen eine Entscheidung
denn die Zeit spielt in dieser Phase des
Krieges eine besondere Rolle die Ukraine
die Menschen in der Ukraine haben nicht
die Zeit für lange Debatten die hier
stattfinden deswegen brauchen wir eine
Lösung wir brauchen ein Ergebnis und ich
finde das auch bemerkenswert ich finde
das gut dass wir jetzige
Verteidigungsminister hingeht und diese
Prüfung vornimmt allerdings ist das
bemerkenswert die Forderung der Ukraine
nach Panzern nach Leopard Panzern die
gibt es seit März 22 dass dieser Vorgang
jetzt das jetzt erst stattfindet ist
schon bemerken sollten jetzt schon
Ukraine ausgebildet werden am Leopard
damit dann alles schneller geht aus
meiner Sicht würde dieser Schritt Sinn
machen sie haben eben diese
Frühjahrsoffensive der Russen
angesprochen die ja von vielen Experten
erwartet wird wenn der Kanzler jetzt
entscheidet keine Leopard freizugeben
Gerät hat damit nicht in die Gefahr
einen möglichen Sieg der Russen in Kauf
zu nehmen das muss man hinterher
bewerten nur eins ist auch völlig klar
wie ich will jetzt nicht die Debatte
auch wenn ich das vorhin so geschildert
habe dass ich hier Ergebnisse erwarte
wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen dass
Deutschland bereits jetzt schon sehr
sehr viel Macht für die Unterstützung
der ukulation ja aber die Prozesse sind
ja gelegentlich da sie müssen sich noch
mal zurück erinnern wie lange hat das
ganze gedauert bis wir die
Schützenpanzer Marder ja geliefert haben
das war ein langer Prozess ich weiß nur
noch mal darauf hin die Zeit haben wir
manchmal nehmen wir uns für diese
Debatten die Menschen in der Ukraine
haben diese Zeit nicht
erreicht danke Ihnen für das Gespräch
sehr gerne